[Music]
our cancellation today deals with
something that i think is real and not a
parody but of course these days you can
never be sure um i always have in the
back of my mind the possibility that
everything happening in our culture
right now is one giant practical joke
you know i'm waiting for someone to bust
into the room at any moment point to the
hidden cameras and explain that my
entire life up to this point has been
the most elaborate prank in history
which is wishful thinking but
i have to hold on to any hope however
faint and it's better than accepting
that
this is real watch
okay this is the fatness spectrum a
small fat is a size 18 and lower 1x or
2x i'm a 4x5x i'm a size 26
sometimes 28. i am the super fat you say
i'm speaking over
just to make sure we're all on the same
page here what we just witnessed in that
video is a morbidly obese woman
responding to the charge
that she's not fat enough to have full
fat credibility in the fat community
she's accused of being a small fat as
opposed to a super fat
but she explains that according to the
fatness spectrum she actually is a super
fat and thus has the authority to speak
about fat issues
according to the fat spectrum she
provides there are four categories of
fats
um small fat mid fat super fat and
infini fat okay now infinifat
sounds like some kind of magical crystal
that a fat person might go on a quest to
obtain so they can become the greatest
the most powerful fat in the world
and that's only sort of what it means in
reality an infinite fat is someone who
wears size 6x clothing basically
if you have to go to a truck stop weigh
station to find out your weight um then
you're an
infinite
and you're also going to be dead very
soon that's the bad news the good news
is that for the remainder of your life
you have enormous credibility in the fat
community
and i do mean enormous
now i did uh some research into the
fatness spectrum to confirm that this is
a real thing and by real i mean a fake
thing that was really made up by real
people and to that question i can say
sadly uh yes affirmative it is in my
research the first thing i stumbled
across
was this article on the website bustle
in 2015 in which a woman
wrestles with an identity crisis after
being accused of insufficient obesity
she writes after spending a little over
two decades associating my body with
fatness
i never would have imagined that i'd be
classed as not fat or as a small fat by
anyone's standards yet when i discovered
the body positivity movement and
immersed myself into blogging it felt
like small fat was the first thing a lot
of humans saw you see within fat
acceptance bubbles on the internet
there's one body type that often
receives a bit of flack the small fat is
essentially someone who might identify
as fat or plus size but who
simultaneously fits into a smaller size
on the plus size spectrum the small fat
is likely allotted some some amount of
thin privilege with others sometimes
deeming it a body type not fat enough to
self-identify as such
now for what i understand
this is why the fat gang has an
initiation ritual where you're forced to
freebase pixie stix
and anyone who refuses is revealed to be
an undercover small fat and is then
immediately killed
fortunately teen vogue the ultimate
authority in insane bullcrap has written
a helpful explainer about the fat
spectrum
in their ask a fat girl column they
explain
these are designations on the spectrum
of fatness a set of terms created by and
for the fat community to self-identify
one's size
these fat these size categories aren't
universally agreed upon folks can
identify however they please but serve
as a general outline for where one falls
on the spectrum of fat privilege those
who fall on the smaller end of the
science spectrum are afforded more
privileges than those on the opposite
end the further you go on the larger
side of the spectrum the more likely a
person is to face discrimination
institutional size-ism be denied medical
care face troubling
face trouble accessing public spaces and
more within the fat community these
designations allow for a shorthand when
sharing information for instance if i'm
in if i'm in need of a new pair of jeans
i can ask a facebook group i'm a mid-fat
looking for some new wide-leg jeans any
suggestions
that way those who respond know what
general category of store i would be
able to fit in what store i would be
able to fit in
so we're going real infinite fat here
gotta look i don't know
i need to i gotta go shopping and i
gotta know what store i can fit in will
i fit in walmart
if you're if you're
so fat that you don't fit in a walmart
then that's not that's like i don't know
that's not infinite fat that's beyond
what's beyond infinifat
uh
galactic fat i don't know
by the way the categories of fatness are
referred to as categories
like ironically that's what they call
them how they make that up categories
incidentally that's the term i've always
used to group fast food restaurants
together i have different categories for
fast food arby's is in the highest
ranking category because if you try to
if you tried like a super size me
experiment and ate only arby's for a
month you'd gain 600 pounds and then
your bowels would explode
that's also why arby's is the best fast
food restaurant
but
also by the way in any case
what can we take away from all of this
well nothing new um but there are two
things worth considering once again i
think first we see the modern leftist
obsessive and compulsive need to label
themselves
now when i was growing up it was cool to
declare yourself independent of all
labels people would say well i don't
really believe in labels i don't do
labels and this was kind of silly but it
at least superficially encouraged people
to form distinct and independent
personalities
right it was kind of a strike against uh
conformity
of course the problem was that most of
the people that went around talking
about how they're non-conformist and
they don't believe in conformity
those are the people that conformed the
most
but in theory again superficially it's
it's a it's a a good thing i guess to
encourage people not to conform just for
the sake of conforming but now on the
left and among the younger generations
in general
people have fled all the way to the
other extreme relentlessly inventing new
categories and categories to hide
themselves in
the labels stand in place of
identity or personality
it's like a weird sort of credentialism
but these credentials are even more
meaningless and arbitrary than the
credentials of a traditional
credentialist
second of course these are people who
along with giving up on developing real
human personalities and identities have
also given up on success improvement
self-betterment
fat acceptance like so many other types
of acceptance is a form of despair
they clamor for the highest victim
status competing with each other over
who's oppressed the most or really who
is oppressing themselves the most by
eating themselves to death the quickest
and they do this because
they don't even desire to live
successful and joyful lives
pity and affirmation is all they seek
that's why we acceptance acceptance i
mean what a weak
meager kind of pitiful
thing that is to want out of life that's
all you want just acceptance
you don't want more than that you're not
you're not setting your your sights any
higher than that i just want to be
accepted
but this is the only pleasure that
they've ever known pity affirmation
or the only pleasure they ever want to
know
well that and eating
and they look for nothing more in life
it is sad pathetic
quite depressing
and that is why super fats small fats
mid fats infini fats and the whole
fatness spectrum
all of that today
is cancer
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated